thank you very much that's a very uh
nice introduction and I'd like to thank
you Gareth for bringing me in reaching
out to me
um this this is a set of topics in the
uh series that I'm I'm very interested
in how do we shape our our character
through the interventions that we make
um I'd also like to thank the University
of Wurzburg a place I've never been to
although I've been not far from there uh
as I was stationed in Germany many many
years ago when I was a soldier I was in
Fert which is you know good ways from
from verzberg or various kind of a large
place but um
yeah I'm hoping someday uh
covet passed to to get over there and
that would be quite quite fun so the the
theme of the series is
um really quite quite a good one I think
it's a very rich and provocative topic
that you know as you can see by the
other people who are in the series it
can be looked at from a number of
different perspectives or thinkers or
schools of philosophy and I thought you
know
I would I would focus in on the stoics
and in particular Epictetus for a few
reasons that I'll get to shortly but
first I'd like to like bring up just one
line from his his works this is in the
discourses uh book one chapter 15. he
tells us that each person's own life
their bios is the subject matter the
hulae the the literally the the stuff
that you work on of the art of living
and that's that's really what we're
looking at here how do we how do we live
well or you might say it in another way
how do we move from living in a crappy
deficient way to a way that's that's
less so
so when I proposed this I thought it
would be worthwhile to focus on the
stoic School in part because the stoics
are all about reasons in a number of
interconnected manners I mean you could
call the stomach's rationalists of A
Sort if you want to and
um you know I'm not going to presume any
great
um background on anybody's part with the
stoics or Epictetus in particular so
that there are a few things I'd like to
say about them the another reason I
wanted to bring them up is that after
largely being ignored or misinterpreted
in academic philosophy since roughly the
early 19th century we're talking about
Hegel just a little bit before this
Hagel is a great misinterpreter of the
stoics as is Aleister McIntyre who gets
criticized by Anthony long for precisely
that but there's been a lot of attention
and interest devoted to the stoics in
the last half century in academic uh
fora and then you know in the last two
decades I think you could say there has
been a continually growing contemporary
interest in stoicism in a popular sense
and so it's it's um worth figuring out
what did they actually think
why are we focusing on Epictetus in
particular well one reason is that he's
my favorite stoic philosopher so if I'm
giving the talk why not but
um
the ways in which he reinterprets
stoicism also fit very nicely with the
theme of this talk series and he's also
quite influential on later philosophers
so I think you know that's another good
reason to talk about them so my my plan
is to you know say a few General things
about the stoic School some of the
distinctive aspects of their their
viewpoints and talk about the importance
of the rational or ruling part in their
anthropology and then we'll turn to
Epictetus I call him a conservative
stoic innovator he's reinterpreting
several key ideas that are going to be
quite important for us including that of
proiracis and the bulk of the talk uh
the idea that I originally pitched to
Gareth was epictetus's views on how we
structure prior races through practical
reasoning as well as through its own
activity of volition making some reasons
matter more or less for ourselves so
there's a you know reason itself and
then there's reasons and the pry racist
plays a really important role in that
and I think that we'll have plenty of
time for Q a which can be you know as
far ranging as as you like once we're
done but in order to not have our
Collective eyes all glaze over I thought
we would take a few breaks in the course
of the talk
um and do some you know q a and
discussion at particular points just to
make sure everybody's on track and also
to break it up a little bit so that by
the end of the talk you're still all you
know paying attention and engaged
because I've been in many many academic
conferences I know my own limits when it
comes to endurance that way and so it's
kind of good to set things up that way
so the stoic school right who who are
these people it arises in Athens in
roughly the third Century BCE there's
this guy Zeno of kittium and you might
know the story about him having a
fortunate shipwreck he loses all of his
investment in Royal Purple you know the
the dye he literally sees his uh Fortune
ebbing away into the the Mediterranean
Sea and then he begins looking for
something to do he goes to a
bookseller's stall he reads a book about
Socrates in xenophon says where can I
find a guy like this and the Bookseller
says see that guy over there Kratos go
uh go talk to him and so he begins
studying with uh
members of Three Socratic schools
Kratos the cynic polymo the academic and
stillpo the magarian and he winds up
producing a new synthesis of his own
something that is really going to catch
on
um you know originally they're just
called the xenonians but then they get
called the people of the stoa because
that's where they would gather and he
gathers an entire uh school to himself
and he it's oriented around attaining
happiness the way a lot of ancient
virtue ethics is he brings in an idea
that's not unique to the stoics but the
stoics certainly do a lot with living in
accordance with nature
virtue as being the only good Vice as
being the only bad and then other things
being indifferent and one of the
handouts that I've I've you know
provided is about that very topic The
Good The Bad and The indifference in
stoic moral theory which is kind of
distinctive as opposed to say
aristotelians or platonists or you know
definitely epicureans who would say that
pleasure is a good the stoics will say
pleasure is nice but it's not a good per
se it's an indifferent one that we we
prefer
um but no amount of pleasure is actually
going to make you happy
um or or good or anything like that
likewise no amount of pleasure is going
to make you bad
um so they're not anti-pleasure or
anything like that as you see with
certain of the the cynics and like a lot
of the ancient schools
um stoicism can be understood as what
pirado famously calls a philosophy as a
way of life
there's other ways of talking about this
Michelle Foucault talks about
Technologies of the self Alistair
McIntyre talks about tradition
constituted rationalities and stoicism
is one of those it's something that's
not only studied but but lived and
there's a dialectic between you know the
theory and the practice you you can as
Epictetus says you can read as many
books of Chrissy purposes you'd like now
we can't of course because they're all
lost but back in his time you could but
that's not actually going to transform
into action and you're not fully
understanding crucifus if you're not
um working you know through these ideas
in your your ordinary life and there's a
continued development of the school it's
actually it becomes one of the major
schools of antiquity a lot of cool
developments that are happening because
they're engaging with the other schools
and argument and debate and discussion
and every once in a while taking an idea
that they like from them which is a you
know pretty par for the course in
ancient philosophy
um
we typically distinguish it into an
older stowa a middle stoa and then a
late a Roman stoa the old stoa Xeno gets
that started and then there's like a
clear line of succession with Clay
anthis crucipus Zeno of Tarsus diogenes
of Babylon Auntie Potter of Tarsus and
they don't all get along with each other
or they they do get along but they don't
all agree with each other there's some
famous debates that happen uh for
example
diogenes and anti-potter differ on the
matter of whether you can effectively
price gouge uh is that okay to do is
that ethical diogenes says yes
anti-potra says definitely not and so
there's a lot of interesting back and
forth stuff going on the middle stoa
panatius the the last of the skolarx who
relocates to Rhodes poseidonius among
others there tends to be a lot more
engagement with the other schools now
I'm fortunately when it comes to what
the old and the Middle stowa Road we
don't have any of their books we have at
best you know passages that are being
cited or things that are derived from
that from them like penatius is on
duties it's taken by Cicero and becomes
the core for Cicero's book on duties but
but we know that Cicero's book goes
beyond pinatius's stuff so it's really
what the later or Roman stoa that we
have
um literature left and you know as as
happens with philosophical schools over
the course of centuries they're
responding to new situations like living
in a Roman Empire you know run by an
autocrat like you know Caesar as as uh
Epictetus will say
um you know they're they're rethinking
the doctrines there's a continual
development that's going on and uh you
know the key people that are associated
with that that we have literature from
would be Seneca who we have the most of
and then Epictetus would be the second
mussonius Rufus this epictetus's teacher
we have some of his stuff we also have
Marcus Aurelius the uh Roman Emperor and
we have Heracles uh some of his stuff as
well and bits and pieces of other things
here and there
the stoic school is going to disappear
as an independent school by the Middle
Ages but in part that's because it's um
it's quite successful in getting some of
its ideas adapted by Christian thinkers
and you'll see a lot of references to
the stoics in say boethius or Augustine
even Thomas Aquinas who kind of gets
them wrong
we'll we'll talk about the stoics at
different points and then in the in the
early modern era we see a recovery of
texts and we see a Reawakening of
interest in stoicism so there's quite a
lot of influence in early modern
philosophy and the Renaissance so what
do the stoics actually think about
things
um
unsurprisingly like most ancient schools
of philosophy they looked at human
beings as being the rational animal
right so this fits in very well we we
have reason we are going to give reasons
and we're not the only rational beings
for the ancient stoics because there's
also god with a capital G you could say
Zeus who is the whole of the cosmos
right an idea that most modern stoics
kind of put aside uh it's a bit
implausible in the present there's also
God's lowercase G that we can think of
as doing the role of you know angels in
uh you know like later Christian thought
or the dimones and neoplatonic thought
they're kind of you know responsible for
getting things done within the cosmos
but they're not they're not in charge
and the stoics uh hold out this Prospect
of because we're rational animals we
participate within what Epictetus and
Seneca will call a commonwealth of human
beings and the gods
um that's our higher nature
um they're also materialists
um there's you know inert matter there's
penoma or this this you know force that
that connects things together and makes
things happen uh which can be more or
less complexly articulated and you know
it can go through a number of different
stages if you're familiar with with
neoplatonic ideas about degrees of being
the stoics have basically the same thing
going on there's you know uh just bare
being plants who grow but they're not
sentient animals and then there's
rational beings like us and the gods
they're also and this may be something
that we want to discuss a little bit
later on they're also determinists of A
Sort
um I mean we would strictly say that
they're compatibilists but their
compatibilism is often quite difficult
to understand how it's supposed to work
we're again a bit handicapped by not
having crucipus to read because he
talked quite a bit about this
Epictetus clearly thinks that we have
freedom because he talks about it all
the time so you know there is a causal
determinism and yet at the same time we
can modify that we can we have a little
bit of Freedom that we can use to to
change the conditions of things or
another way you can think about it is we
can be
self-causing in certain respects or if
you like an older terminology we can be
self-moved movers but only to a certain
degree right
and um perhaps more distinctive
commitment that's that's really
important here
so you know if you know Plato if you
know Aristotle they have a psychology
that we call a faculty psychology right
where
um Plato you know for example has the
rational part of the soul the the
appetites and then this middle part
thumos and it's difficult to translate
effectively the spirited the passionate
the incandescent part of the soul but
each of these is like a bit that does
its own thing right and the appetites
are like totally irrational the Thematic
part can listen to reason but it's not
truly rational the rational part is
rational the stoic see things
differently
so the stoics think that we have
basically eight faculties five of them
are the senses so we can put them aside
because all they do is like register
information and maybe like seek out
information
and then there's the uh faculty of
reproduction you know not particularly
important for what we're looking at the
faculty of speech and then there's this
eighth faculty that they call the
hegemony cone the ruling part and this
is you know what we would call the Mind
proper in when you know when Seneca is
talking about it he'll call it the
Animus in Latin
um
Epictetus is going to you might say
widen its scope a little bit and this is
where we find reason or rationality in
our other intellectual functions you
know so it's definitely the rational
part of the Soul he uh well the stoics
in general say that this is the part
that uses and understands what they call
appearances or Impressions Fantasia
which we could also translate as
imagination and it's also this is where
it's different than say the Aristotelian
or the platonic view it's also where we
feel or think emotions passions and
affects so it's all happening in this
one place within us and these include
not just the emotions but also desire
and aversion
choice and rejection and this part of
the soul is also concerned with Ascent
suncata thesis in Greek and with all the
other things that are connected with it
so really everything that's important
for our own responses our our ways of
engaging with the world besides the
senses and you know having sex and
saying things it's all happening in this
rational ruling part of the soul for the
stoics
so that is you know a significant
difference
I do need to say a little bit about
stoic ethics and the philosophy of
action that they have so you know like
most ancient uh virtue ethics there is
an overarching and a Telos of goods and
they describe it as uh happiness or
eudaimonia there's also some other cool
formulations like a smooth flow of life
right uh which I guess you could think
of as like things going your way and
everything coming together well they use
words like Tranquility you know ataraxia
or apathaya living in accordance with
nature is also a really really key idea
for them a very complicated idea
and uh the good for them
is essentially virtue and whatever
participates in in virtue so the virtues
and then you know good actions
um good relationships those sorts of
things and then the bad is going to be
uh what's opposed to that vices and
everything else is basically an
indifferent everything else falls into
this this giant sphere some things are
totally indifferent like the number of
hairs on your head whether it's odd or
even
one that I always like to bring up with
the stoics that they also thought was
indifferent the color of your skin
um they thought that didn't matter for
anything very different than what we see
in many parts of the world and uh our
long history right
um but there's also you know a lot of
things that are they're not strictly
speaking good they're indifference but
they're you could I'm gonna play a
little bit on words they're good
indifference they're they're preferred
indifference right they have value oxia
and then there's those that have dis
value so it's not like being rich is in
itself a good thing and it doesn't make
you virtuous and it probably won't make
you happy by itself but wealth is a
preferred and different and poverty is a
just preferred indifferent so Epictetus
is inheriting this this whole schema you
could say and I do want to say one other
thing and then we'll take a little
short short q a Break by the time that
we want to study philosophy or even just
think about the good life we are
typically screwed up we've already been
damaged corrupted gotten things wrong
we've got bad habits not only of action
but also of Mind we've had all sorts of
bad examples provided to us our culture
has has imposed all sorts of you know
mistaken Notions upon us and so we need
some straightening out we need some
moral development and
um Epictetus says and this is in uh book
1 chapter 26 of his discourses
this is a starting point in philosophy
perception isasis of the state of One's
Own governing principle so realizing how
screwed up you are and of course you
can't realize how how screwed up you are
completely you you get to see like
surface level things you're like oh I I
get angry too easily what's going on
there you know I've been to anger
management classes and did some
cognitive behavior therapy and I'm still
getting angry at people well that's your
governing principle that you got to take
a look at and see you know if to use one
of the metaphors that we have here in
the States you gotta look under the hood
right at the car and see what's uh
what's wrong is it out of oil
um is there something burning you know
pick whatever you like now obviously we
can't work on very modern cars anymore
you've got to take it into the shop
because they're far too complicated but
assuming that you could actually do it
um it would it would be you know what
Epictetus is telling us we need to do so
before we jump into
Epictetus himself
any any questions so far things that we
need to get clear about or
um
you know we don't want to go off the
path too much yeah go ahead anyone can
go off
um Mike if you want to and just ask what
you want or or you can put it in the
chat too
so that's that's a good question you
could frame it in terms of is the
capacity for communication part of the
way in which we structure our thoughts
right and emotions and things like that
I mean I think from the present
perspective where you know we have
centuries and centuries of of realizing
that communication is connected up with
our our rationality and our emotions and
all these things we would probably say
yeah there's probably a much closer
connection the ancient stomachs I think
what they and and we don't really we
don't have any treatises on this but I
think what they mean by The Faculty of
speech is just the capacity to like
articulate
so
um I mean you could also say
what about reproduction right we're
sexual beings uh shouldn't this be part
of it I mean we have a desire for it and
and the stoics I don't know exactly why
I mean the senses it makes sense why
they would put them aside but why would
they consider those two things speech
and reproduction to be like their own
separate faculties
um I don't think we have really good
explanations for that I mean it doesn't
play a huge role for Epictetus as as
we're going to see he's mostly
interested in what we're doing with any
of our faculties and it's all centered
on this this rational ruling part
so that's a very important question
though I think if we're going to try to
adapt this to Modern Times
any other questions or yeah yeah so so
the question is whether there's a
connection between this stoic ideal of
living in accordance with nature and
then their epistemology their theory of
knowledge I mean there there are
connections
um but again unfortunately we're kind of
handicapped by mostly learning about
this through critics of the stoics like
um Cicero and the on academics and
Plutarch in certain respects and then
sexist empiricus in particular right
because he he goes after everybody
and the stoics um
I mean they they were committed to this
idea that we could have
um what they called cotyleptica Fantasia
that is Impressions that we can't
possibly be wrong about right and you
know you could say when that's the case
you're like grasping reality as it truly
is before you
um they seem to think that this was
quite important
um you don't see Epictetus particularly
worried about this
um and even Seneca isn't particularly so
by the time of the Roman stoa they're
they're less concerned with this but you
get the idea that for the early and the
middle store this is really
Central the other thing I will say is
that this idea of living in accordance
with nature
it's it's a great slogan Lawrence Becker
in a new stoicism uh one of the very
important books in the academic Revival
actually says this is a this is a
terrible phrase we should get rid of it
it's only done harm right and it's it's
in part because when you look at what
the stoics say about living in
accordance with nature it turns out to
be quite complex
and people always want to reduce it down
to well that just means living
rationally or just means living
virtuously but it's something that was
controversial within the stoics
um you know
crucipus for example said listen it's
not just living in accordance with
nature as like the totality of what is
and you know
um that's not being
in contradiction with it it's also
living in accordance with human nature
uh so and then you say well what you
know people do awful things right uh
human nature seems pretty bad and he's
saying no no no we mean a like a fully
developed Human Nature and then you're
like what is that you know and and
that's where it starts to get more and
more complex and and the stoics every
once in a while will come out of
um left field so to speak with some
remark about what's in accordance with
nature you know mussonius Rufus will
tell us that being a farmer is is the
job that's most in accordance with
nature you know and you're like well
where is this coming from and how does
this help us right and so you've got to
piece together this incredibly complex
composite picture I think in order to
get at a lot of what they they mean by
it but yeah knowledge does play an
important role I don't know that we
necessarily need to be absolutely
certain about things
in order to be able to run our lives
well you know that's that's the
impression I get from Epictetus that
we're not going to get to the point of
having these like absolutely
foundational perceptions about things
we're continually
refining our our understanding of things
and so it's more of an approximative
thing than like a on off switch
um I see another question from uh Sonia
a lot of good questions about the
emotions
um the stoic idea is that about the
emotions is that every one of them does
have a cognitive content which is not
unique in in ancient virtue ethics I
mean Aristotle says that about the
emotions too right in rhetoric book two
but the stoics consider every emotion to
include not just the affective state but
also some sort of judgments that's being
made typically wrong
because you know they there's this this
caricature of the stoics as being like
anti-emotional you know oh emotions are
bad stuff them down that's not quite
true
but you can say that they do think a lot
of our emotions are intrinsically bad
for us so like there's no right amount
of anger for the stoics right but anger
is a complex thing that does include
judgments like the Judgment that we've
been wrong the Judgment or the inference
that it was it was um unjust that we
were wronged in this way we should get
revenge retaliation there's a whole
bunch of moving parts right now about
um the thing that you asked about like
are there some that we we just can't you
know like do anything with right so
Seneca interestingly thinks that once
you start feeling a strong passion and
you have ascented to it you basically
are stuck and you can no longer resist
that you you're stuck acting on the
basis of that emotion like anger for
example
now Epictetus doesn't really agree with
him Epictetus says you can reason with
somebody who is angry it's just very
difficult to do right so how much think
of like the ruling part is like being a
container Seneca is saying
um once you've allowed that container to
get filled up 51 with anger
um anger's running the show until until
you're no longer angry right and
um you know there might be 49 of reasons
still left in there but it doesn't
matter because whatever is in charge is
in charge Epictetus is a little bit more
optimistic on the capacity for us to
reason with ourselves or others to
reason with us when we're angry or sad
or I mean what else uh unduly fearful or
um ashamed or you know things things
like that so yeah
well let's let's uh I mean there will be
plenty of time for more questions
um let's talk about Epictetus himself
so I I mentioned I think of him as a
conservative stoic innovator
he's very clearly drawing on and
referencing and even using in his own
teaching because he was a teacher
previous stomach philosophers
um he mentions crucipus incessantly as
well as his teacher masonous Rufus but
he also
um deviates from the other stoics in
some very interesting ways he discusses
the term virtue much much less he brings
it up only at a few points in the the
discourses and his teaching about it
shows that he like totally understands
the stoic point of view he's actually
got a passage where he's like anybody
can give a discourse about virtue and
vice
um the real test is whether they can
actually put that into practice and what
they do when somebody interrupts them
can they can they get back on track with
it or not if not then it was just kind
of surface level stuff he'll talk a lot
more about like Freedom or Tranquility
or or interestingly faithfulness
um you know being trustworthy a sense of
Shame aim or self-respect idos and then
he he's constantly hammering on this in
accordance with nature thing but he's
also going to change the way that's
framed as well he introduces
um these famous three disciplines that
we don't find anywhere else in the
stoics as a matter of fact we find three
disciplines that are a little bit
different in Seneca when he talks about
ethics
um
he focuses very heavily on some things
that are
more important in other schools of
philosophy like for example
prolapsis which we translate as uh
preconceptions or general conceptions
that's that appears to be originally a
idea coming from maybe the epicureans
it's definitely not a primarily stoic
idea
um the what's in our control what's not
in our control that that people take a
lot from Epictetus because it's right
there in you know n Caribbean one the
feminine and effemine
that is an Aristotelian term originally
as is proiracis
and Epictetus is taking these and he's
doing things that are they're not not
stoic but they're sort of expanding the
scope of stoic Philosophy by doing that
and so This this term priorases that I I
wanted to concentrate on for this talk
um it's used by a lot of earlier authors
like the masthenese the Socrates Plato
it'll get used later by Philo of
Alexandria and Plutarch but it has more
importance in the Aristotelian tradition
because Aristotle views it as you know
the the part of ourself that like makes
decisions that engages in it's often
translated as moral choice or
deliberative Choice
um it's not particularly important for
the stoics before Epictetus it's it's
rendered as Choice before a choice which
kind of makes sense right Pro before
high races uh choice
and there's no reference whatsoever to
it in mussonius Rufus it's not a term
that's Cicero notes being used and in
need of having a Latin translation uh we
don't see it in Heracles uh who might be
a contemporary of Epictetus there's
minimal use of it Marcus Aurelius so we
can say well what the hell is it doing
there in Epictetus then well it's
absolutely Central to his his entire
philosophy you could say that this is
one of the main contributions that he is
making and there's a lot of different
ways we can translate this just to give
you some of the English translations
faculty of choice Power of Choice moral
purpose disposition volition long will
actually translate it occasionally as
thus self which I think is
understandable but not completely right
moral character moral personality and
then Michael Freda will will translate
it as the will as have some other people
as well so what what is this prior
racist if we look to Epictetus
um there's there's a number of different
characteristics and I'm just going to
mention four of them
one is that it really is the core of who
you are it's the core of the person
um he at one point he says you are for a
racist and that's you know about as
unequivocal as you can get
um he also tells us you're not flesh or
hair but prior racist so if you get that
beautiful then you will be beautiful so
there's an identification of the you the
acting subject with your priorases
um at another point he says that you're
not flesh or bones or sinews but that
which uses them governs and understands
appearances so we're getting you might
see where we're going with this uh a
little bit of foreshadowing there
it's also the ethical Locus he tells us
over and over again good and evil lie in
the prior races I mean it's not as if
nothing else is good or evil but that is
the primary location you could say and
at one point he actually says and this
is a in book 3 chapter 10 outside of
prairie races there is nothing either
good or bad and it kind of makes sense
if you know virtue and vice are what's
really good or bad
um the thing that does the choosing the
thing that's shaping itself could could
work that way prairacis is also free
it's the locus of our our freedom and so
he says that nobody is actually Master
over another person's priorases unless
that person chooses to allow that to
happen so if you you know if if you're
looking for my praise and that matters
to you I become your master
because uh you're seeking something that
I actually have control over he goes so
far as to say that not even Zeus the God
you know that that is the whole universe
can hinder my moral purpose my prayer
races
um so that's you know if Zeus can't then
really nobody can
um he tells us that nothing outside of
the sphere of prayer races can hamper or
injure
racist it alone can hamper or injure
itself and that's a very important uh
thing to point out because
when we talk about like shaping our
character and giving reasons we are the
ones typically who screw ourselves up
from an from an epictetian stoic
perspective
um the other thing that I think is a
really important aspect that we're going
to talk quite a bit about is the Prairie
races it's you know if you think about
this Choice before a choice another way
of thinking about it is the pro is
choosing one thing instead of another
thing in place of another thing
prioritization we could say or if you
like preference
um you know sort of like the the German
uh uh
Fair name and right is there for foreign
that you see like in mock Shaler you
know phenomenologists of value right you
prefer some things over others the
Prairie racist does that right and so we
have a lot of examples of having to
choose between something that's less
valuable and the priorases itself being
a certain way and this is a choice that
you make through the Prairie races
so this shows us it's a pretty powerful
faculty now how does this fit in with
the ruling faculty or the rational
faculty
some Scholars like Anthony long want to
say that they're not exactly the same
thing that you can make a distinction
between them
and you know there's a lot of other
uh traditions in philosophy that say
that we have you know reason or the
rational faculty or the intellect over
here to the cognitive faculty and then
we have the faculty of volition or
choice or however you're going to Define
it over here and they you know they work
together a lot of the time but they're
they're distinct from each other
um and you can say you know this is
cognitive versus effective or volitional
Epictetus uh talks in such a way as to
make it plausible to say that prior
racist actually is the rational faculty
actually is the ruling faculty all three
of these are different ways of talking
about the same basic thing
and this is I think pretty distinctive
not just in um
stoic philosophy but in philosophy in in
general
um
so you know why should we why should we
think this is the the case there's
really three main reasons that I've
isolated out and talked about elsewhere
that stem from uh his his writings
themselves and from common features so
when it comes to good and evil right he
tells us that good and evil reside
within the scope of the prior racist so
what about the the rational and
governing faculties he tells us in uh
book two chapter eight what is the true
nature of the good it's intelligence
news knowledge epistemate right reason
orthos logos in use and understanding of
appearances uh he also tells us the
ruling faculty of a bad person is not to
be trusted I mean because it's their
prior racist and uh in book three he
tells us the subject matter with which
the good and excellent person has to
deal with is their own governing faculty
so you know if prior racist is where
good and evil reside then it looks like
either it's in the the governing faculty
or it just is the governing faculty
there's also a stronger case that's
provided by the reflexivity of proiracis
and of the rational and ruling for
faculty so what is reflexivity it's when
something Bears upon itself I mean a
silly instance is the old Liars Paradox
this sentence is false right it's
reflexive it's referring to itself
um but when we take a position on our
own selves when we regret something and
we're like oh I shouldn't have said that
to that person or oh I uh I did the
wrong thing I made a bad choice we are
reflecting on ourselves right and this
is part of the nature of being a a human
being by being a rational being so
um he tells us in book one chapter one
that the rational faculty is the only
one which is self-contemplating
self-approving or condemning one that
makes use of appearances Fantasia one
that bears upon other faculties so if
the rational faculty is the only one
that does that
and that's also what prayer racist does
I think you can see the conclusion prior
racist is the rational faculty right
um he'll also tell us uh similarly in
book one chapter 17. nothing is superior
to reason and analyzes it because reason
analyzes itself on two book two chapter
23 Prairie races is the
self-contemplating faculty
um
and there's a number of other things
that could be said similar to that the
whole Conformity to Nature being in
accordance with nature
um he constantly talks about keeping
prey racist in accordance with nature he
also talks about keeping the ruling
faculty in accordance with nature so if
there isn't a complete coincidence
between
prior racist rash the rational faculty
and the ruling faculty
they're pretty close they're you could
say that they overlap and there's just a
tiny little bit of
um non-coincidence between them now
there's a really important upshot for
this in terms of giving reasons and how
we use reasons in one a chapter book one
chapter 28 he says what is the reason we
Ascend to anything the fact that it
appears to us to be so this is the
nature of the intellect to agree to what
is true to be dissatisfied with what is
false and to withhold judgment from what
is uncertain so when a person ascends to
a falsehood rest assured it's not their
wish to ascend to it as false and then
he says in the sphere of actions what we
have corresponding to what do we have
corresponding to the true and false Duty
and contrary to duty the useful the not
useful what is appropriate to me and
what is not and similar things so we've
got like reasoning processes going on
over here in the rational faculty you
know can concerned with truth and
falsity and nobody wants to ascend to
what is false and then all the other
stuff the action the choices the
um affective stuff there's a similar
logic going on and they they basically
map on to each other for Epictetus
when he talks about error he says every
error involves a contradiction in Greek
a conflict right we could translate it
as if we don't want contradiction
who is an error does not wish to err but
to be right and it's clear they're not
doing what they want to do
he says every rational soul is offended
by contradiction and so that so long as
a person doesn't understand that they're
involved in contradiction there's
nothing to prevent them from doing
contradictory things but when they've
come to understand the contradiction
they have to of necessity abandon and
avoided it just as bitter necessity
compels a person to renounce the false
when they perceive that it's false but
as long as the falsehood doesn't appear
they assent to it as truth
so a person who can show to another the
contradiction that causes them to err
and can bring home to them how they're
not doing what they want to do and is
doing what they don't want to do is as
he says strong in argument in logo right
and effective in encouragement
protrepticos and in refutation a lengthy
course these are sort of you know kind
of common modes of discourse in ancient
philosophy so what is he saying there
he's saying
um you know there's like again this
cognitive side you you don't want to be
involved in getting things wrong uh in
terms of your intellect but in terms of
what you're choosing to do how you're
living your life what you're committing
to it's exactly the same thing and if
you want somebody to change it it you
can't just like yell at them or you know
punish them you got to show them how
they've got things fundamentally wrong
and then and then they will uh want to
change it
um
there's a good bit I'm going to skip
over a little bit here because I I want
to be cognizant of of time here but how
we can say how does pray racist actually
work on itself right
so it determines itself
and one way that we don't do it
um the way that Epictetus thinks about
it is it's not like there's a little
tiny person inside of ourself that looks
like it's a homunculus as we call it and
that's the Prairie races
um you know perfectly conscious
arranging deciding that's just an
imagination that we have and that's
that's not like what we experience and
that's not what Epictetus tells us
Epictetus tells us instead what is
reason it is a system a Systema a
connected network of fantasy appearances
and we could say the same thing about
our prior racist what is it really well
it's a bunch of habits it's a bunch of
desires and aversions it's a bunch of
um things that we've chosen to do that
have had their effects on us it's also
the thing that's doing that stuff it is
US acting on ourselves and
um we we you know we work on it through
how we choose how we commit to things he
tells us that nothing is capable of
hindering prayer races as we as we've
talked about it nothing that lies
outside of its sphere but only itself
when it has become perverted or or go on
astray and through this it becomes the
only Vice the only virtue it uses all
the other faculties and these are good
they're just not or important but
they're just not as important as as
proiracis and so we can ask well
how does it how does it fix itself how
does it become more prudent or more
rational and a lot of this is through
cognitive means and this goes right to
our theme of reason and reasons right so
you apply reason through prior races to
bring the governing principle back in
line he tells us in 218 this is this is
a place where he's talking about all
three of these working together and he
says that um what we have to do is look
at our and it's translated in different
ways our dog Mata our judgments our
opinions the things that we assert right
or the things that we buy into
um we need to look at those we need to
be very careful with with those things
and also our assumptions are Hoople
lapses
so we we work on those and we try to get
those better we try to get them you know
more in accordance with how things
actually are whether about intellectual
theoretical matters or about moral
matters and as we do that gradually we
get better and better
and one way we can do this like he says
is he says let a person transfer their
judgments to matters that lie within the
province of prairaces and I guarantee
that they will be steadfast whatever the
state of things may be this is a
constant theme in in Epictetus so we
have to have you know like continual
attention to these choices that need to
be made this is what he calls Pros okay
or paying attention another important
value
and we
um gradually develop a life where we're
more conscious of what we're doing with
ourselves in relation to all of these
things that belong to us like our
desires our beliefs our judgments about
things the things that people have told
us that we've bought into uh as well as
the environment that we live in which
includes many other people and things
that are that are going on so this is I
mean there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that could be said about the um
how we transform Prairie races but let's
take a little pause here because that's
already a lot that I've thrown at you uh
answer a few questions and then we'll
talk about
um habituation I've got one key theme uh
that ties in with how how this works in
in practice and then we can explore some
other things
um
okay so so she says how is reason
connected with appearances so
appearances are Fantasia this this um
this term that covers a whole wide range
of things they're not all necessarily
external
um and some of them might be
imaginations some of them might be
memories they cover it's a term that
covers a huge scope of things
Epictetus tells us at one point that
reason itself logos is a system a
sustema a connected network of bless of
appearances
and so there's no like one single thing
that is reason in Epictetus it's
understood basically as like a whole
composite thing that's that's put
together which is kind of good news
because it means like there's no node
that could be destroyed that would then
render us completely
reason less you know irrational but it
also if you think about it it also means
that we're never quite done with putting
it together it's not as if we have a
faculty of reason that we start out with
and it's just perfect and then it gets
screwed up
we're continually building it and you
can say a similar thing with our our
Prairie races you know we're continually
building it when we were little kids uh
some of it was being built by us but
much more was being built by our parents
for good or bad or our teachers or you
know whoever else right and since
Prairie races and and the faculty of
Reason are sort of like
two different ways of looking at the
same thing you could say that prioracis
is also a sustema a net a network or a a
matrix of of things so I'm sure there's
some other questions as well
well Epictetus is a stoic and so and he
doesn't Define Freedom either as as
self-causing that's just
um one aspect of it you could say I mean
when we think about this term Freedom
itself it's it's an ambiguous term right
um it encompasses a number of different
aspects
and
um being able to cause yourself is one
or being able to like determine yourself
we could say as well is one key part of
it but you're you're never like totally
able to change yourself all at once are
you I mean you can you can sort of like
focus on this part as opposed to this
part and try to fix this thing over here
but it's it's sort of like um you know
are all of you familiar with
whack-a-mole that that game where you
try to you have to hit the thing and it
pops up and then it pops up in another
location so the moral progress is kind
of like that you're you're continually
trying to work on uh one thing and then
another thing pops up over here and you
you work on that thing as well but
you're free to do that right you and and
you could say well how free uh just a
little bit you know we don't have to be
totally able to transform ourselves in a
moment in order to to be free
um and and the other interesting aspect
of it that constantly comes up in
Epictetus isn't talked about so much by
the other Stokes except for Seneca maybe
is that we're we're usually misusing our
our freedom
um this is a theme that also comes up
with you know later thinkers like Anselm
of Canterbury or the existentialists
um we can throw our freedom away
and become as zapatidus will say
enslaved to things because that's the
opposite for him of Freedom so I can
make free choices to
um prioritize some things that I
shouldn't prioritize you know and that
is going to render me over time
um less free you know as I develop
habits for example
um
he thinks that habits are incredibly
important just the confusion about the
self-causing term arises because you're
taking it in too strong of a sense
um it's not as if you like will yourself
into being metaphysically that's not
what it means at all
um it just means that we we have a
capacity to work on ourselves to
determine ourselves I I think so long as
you can keep it at a sort of mundane
level
um it doesn't wind up being that
confusing and if if self-causing winds
up
um
generating confusions just change it to
self-determining you know because that's
that's basically what they mean by it
so
sure yeah I mean we do this all the time
you know showing up here to the uh Zoom
session is a case of all of us
determining ourselves to do something
that we had wanted to do before and then
we follow through on the commitment that
we've we've made to it I mean we do this
constantly
um we often do it wrongly in ways that
that allow other things to determine us
more but I don't think there's there's
much
trickier or mysterious about this unless
we we think like on two grand of a scale
you know again we're not Epictetus
doesn't think that we can like transform
ourselves in an instant into a wonderful
human being but we we do have it like
each moment that we're doing something
we have some capacity to intervene and
choose one thing rather than another or
prioritize one thing rather than another
and I think this is not this is not
particularly stoic
um
Aristotle says similar things about at
least some stuff it's very common in
later uh neoplatonic thought and
Christian thought to say these sorts of
things right so
sure
I see that Sonya has her her hand up as
well
so
the question about reflexivity and
putting it into contemporary terms
reflexivity is a contemporary term I
mean there's an entire tradition called
reflexive philosophy that you find that
includes like Maurice Blondell and Jack
paliard and stuff like that and is it is
it tied in with sort of frankfurti and
higher order lower order things I would
say that
um
you could say that uh we've got this
General category of
accounts that think that the human being
is in some degree with some faculty is
reflexive
and frankfurt's approach to that which
is a very popular one in contemporary
philosophy of action and analytic
circles
um is just one of many possible ways of
articulating that right I think that
frankfurt's account is sometimes helpful
in in some respects but I don't know
that all of this can be understood in
terms of higher and lower order desires
you know
um in part because it's not just desires
but it's it's volitions and it's you
know thoughts about things now
um the other part that you were asking
about like are we completely conscious
about all these things right so
Epictetus isn't Jean-Paul sart is is
kind of famous for very implausibly
saying that um we're basically conscious
of everything you know we just kind of
hide it from ourselves and so like you
know for example psychoanalysis is is
not what it pretends to be because we
don't really have hidden desires that
have to be brought to to Consciousness
start I think overplayed his hand as
Simone de bevoir herself also like said
yeah this is
this is probably wrong right and so but
he represents a certain extreme position
that you do see a lot of people saying
well if you did this thing you must have
been conscious of it I think we're
driven by
um poorly understood desires and and
implicit processes of reasoning all of
the time and Epictetus thinks that too
he thinks that part of what we have to
do is bring these things to light which
sometimes we may not ourselves be able
to do on our own we might need somebody
else to help us out with it like I think
Epictetus would say a good
psychotherapist would would function
almost like a moral philosopher like
he's doing in helping us understand just
how screwed up the the things that we've
committed ourselves to are right and so
um I don't think that he thinks
that we ever have like complete
consciousness of everything that's going
on within our our own psyches or to use
another term that
um Albert Camus loved uh Lucidity I
don't think he thinks that we have
complete Lucidity of of that but now
this is a kind of a it's actually a
great question because so you could say
well though we you know how the hell do
we know that we're on the right track
you know we can have more Consciousness
like you do see some people in life and
you're like that person seems totally
clueless about what they're doing you
know there's like some surface level
thinking going on and then there's all
this other stuff that clearly is
happening but they're not they're not
getting you know uh they need they need
some real you know uh examination or
reflection or pick whatever you want to
use
um over time you can become more
conscious although I think you're
probably always kind of a mess you know
as far as Epictetus is concerned
including himself I mean he says at one
point I'm never going to be Socrates
but I don't have to be I could just be a
good Epictetus so
Stefan has a question as well
so
um the question is what is the new
feature in epictetus's concept of
prairie races in comparison to the older
stoics
there's a couple things that you can say
one is that the ancient the other stoics
didn't pay any attention to Prairie
racist period
and then you could say well yeah but
Seneca and Cicero do talk about
um voluntas and valenciones and you can
say okay there's some some overlap there
right but it's not voluntas like in the
full sense of like augustinian voluntas
uh which looks much more like epictetian
priorases and Michael Freda is willing
to say that epictetian Prairie races
simply is the will
per se I wouldn't go quite so far I
would say that Augustine is still adding
and other thinkers are adding a little
bit more but Epictetus is pretty close
to the the later ancient concept of of
you know the will and
um so there's that and you could also
say it's it's also interesting that he
takes essentially an Aristotelian term
Aristotle is the you know first great
theorist of prairie races and then has
no problem whatsoever using it in
whatever way he wants but he goes beyond
Aristotle for Aristotle if prey racist
is self-determining
um you have to kind of read that in
um it's very clear in appetitus that it
is who you are it is the core of the
person and no earlier stoic says that
right so
that's definitely in advance
um it's its capacity to determine itself
freely without anything else hindering
it unless it chooses to allow that to
happen I would say that that's something
new too and you know can you say well
the the other stoics didn't have any
conception of that and we don't know
because
we don't have the writings I mean we
have summaries of their Doctrine in I
would say Cicero uh aristidymis and
diogenes the irritates but
um maybe they didn't pay attention
to it I I you know it's it's difficult
to say with any certainty right what we
can say is like holy crap for this
Epictetus guy he won't he won't shut up
about this thing right so even if we're
just gonna go buy some you know lexical
thing like word count it's clearly much
more important for him than for any
other philosopher before him
uh and maybe any philosophy after him
you know because I mean who who uses
Greek to uh these days uh to write about
it I will say one other thing too
there's a little bit of a trivia right
so when philosophy is moving from from
Greek into Latin
um I think a lot of confusion got
generated
by the translation it's not pro-racist
that gets translated as voluntas
it's
um oolasis
which which well yeah like rational
um desire right so we see that in Cicero
we see that in Augustine we see that
showing up in Thomas Aquinas when he's
like doing his commentary on Aristotle
proiracis gets translated as liberum
arbitrim
um the you know which is usually like
cast is something like this is what the
will does you know but it's not the will
itself when I think that epictetian
Prairie racist really is like the will
just you know maybe there's there's a
little bit more added to it
um as as things go on but it's pretty
close you know so I'm more or less in
agreement with with Freda on that and I
I think long is actually wrong I don't
think that that um prairace is the
rational faculty and the hegemony cone
are different in Epictetus I think they
they basically are the same thing
let's let's talk a little bit there's
one theme that I wanted to bring up um
and maybe we can come back to the
habituation stuff later if people are
interested in that
is an example of like practical
reasoning how we give ourselves reasons
about things if you've read a lot of
Epictetus you know that he he thinks
that money doesn't really count for much
but he talks about it a lot money prices
costs and exchange and he does so in a
number of ways that fit in nicely with
us so I'm just going to read a bunch of
of passages and we can talk about them
and comment on them so in in uh Book 2
chapter 18 He says once you conceive a
desire for money if reason be applied to
um your you know to your your own
perception of the evil the passion is
still so our affect is changed and the
ruling part is restored to its original
Authority but if you don't apply a
remedy your governing principle doesn't
return to its previous condition but
upon being aroused Again by the
corresponding appearances it goes right
back into the desires even more quickly
and if this happens over and over again
the next stage is that a callousness
results and the infirmity strengthens
the address so In this passage we see
virtue or vice
um applying reasons uh the ruling part
and the choice to do so all connected
together
in in a way that's pretty typical of
Epictetus in book 1 chapter 7 he says
what is the professed object of
reasoning to State the true to eliminate
the false to suspend judgment in
doubtful cases
is it enough to learn this alone and he
says well is it enough for the person
who wants to make no mistake in the use
of money to be told the reason why you
don't why you accept genuine drachmas
and reject the counterfeit what do you
need to add to this a faculty that
actually tests the genuine drachmas and
the counterfeit and distinguishes
between them so there's there's a
similarity to handling currency and
accepting it to how we we reason about
things and
um in chapter three of book two he's
talking about diogenes
um some of you may you know be familiar
with this this practice you're asked to
write a letter of recommendation for
somebody and diogeny says I'm not going
to do that I mean diogenes is a cynic so
he doesn't do a lot of things and he
says it's just as though a coin we're
asking somebody to recommend them in
order to be tested if the person in
question is a tester of silver you're
going to recommend yourself we ought to
have have an everyday life the sort of
thing we have in the case of silver so
that I may be able to say is the assayer
of silver does bring me any drachma you
please and I will appraise it so again
here there's a correspondence between
money and like our appearances or our
reasonings or our character
um in uh book 3 chapter 3 says just it
is just as it is the nature of every
soul to ascend to the true descent from
the fall so you notice this this theme
again right
um so it is its nature to be moved with
desire towards the good with aversion
towards the evil and to feel neutral
towards what is neither evil nor good
okay so so far so good right with a
what's going on in the intellect or
Reason is the same thing that happens in
terms of our orientation towards the
good and our choices and then he says
just as neither the banker or the grocer
May legally refuse the coinage of Caesar
but if you present it whether he wants
to or not he must give you what you're
purchasing with it so it is with the
soul
different people have different pieces
of coinage a person offers the coin and
gets what is bought by it
and he goes on uh as well and he says so
you know we have to think about the the
purchases that we're making the choices
that we're making he says keep this
thought ready at hand whenever you lose
some external thing what are you
requiring in its place if this is more
valuable than the other then don't say
I've suffered a loss you've lost nothing
if you get a horse for an ass an ox for
a sheep a noble action for a small piece
of money
it's no small matter you're guarding but
self-respect Idols Fidelity pistis and
constancy a state of mind understood by
Passion pain fear confusion in a word
Freedom what are the things for which
you were about to sell these things look
how valuable they are
so you know we've almost got like price
tags on things and we have to decide we
have to be Savvy consumers we have to be
you know good purchasers or exchangers
um in book one chapter two talking about
the famous chamber pot thing he says hey
you know yourself how much you're worth
and at what price you sell yourself
people sell themselves for different
prices
consider the price you'll you're willing
to sell your proy races uh for if you
have to sell it then at least don't sell
it cheap I mean ideally you don't sell
it at all but uh get a good bargain if
you're if you're going to do that make
sure that you get something that's going
to make you happy
um and then in um
I'll I'll actually just skip to
ncaridian 25
um he talks about paying prices for
things right and he's talking about
getting invited to dinner parties
um and we can think about all sorts of
other opportunities that are offered to
us and offered to other people and he
says if you don't get invited to the
dinner party well that's because and I'm
going to translate very crudely here you
didn't kiss enough but you know if you
want to get invited to parties you gotta
sell yourself you gotta go around to the
people that are having the parties and
like you know say nice things to them
and tell them things that are you know
uh false about themselves and then
they'll invite you and you know if
somebody else got invited it's because
they did the butt kissing that needed to
be done uh you didn't do it it's
ridiculous for you to expect that you're
going to get something without paying
the price and so he he uses the example
of an old bull and a head of lettuce he
says if you uh you know don't want to
buy the lettuce don't buy the lettuce
but don't complain that you don't have
the lettuce if you've got the oval in
your hand and you could sell it or you
could you could purchase it
um you know you're the one who decides
whether you exchange this or not and so
this this entire metaphor which there's
many many other passages where he he
talks about things in terms of prices
and purchasing and all that
we've all got these these things that
can appeal to us and he talks about you
know like some people
um they're driven by lust the price for
them beautiful bodies some people want
honor the price for them getting you
know Fame and and all of that some
people just want money by itself some
people want pleasure these are all
things that
um if we value them too much
if we value them to the extent that
we're willing to sell ourselves out and
do the wrong thing for them
um we're going to give things power over
us we're going to be determined by them
and all of this is by reasoning
processes whether you know explicit or
implicit and they can be fixed by
reasoning processes but we have to
choose to do so right so if if I see my
friend I mean think about epictetuses
being like our friend and he just
happens to be contained unlike a regular
body in these uh these books here and we
have to read our way through them and
then we can start to apply those reasons
within our life to you know be a little
bit more
clear about what we're doing to
prioritize better to make better choices
to not sell ourselves out for things
that's that's a possibility for us and
so we give ourselves reasons and and I
think that you know Epictetus uses lots
of metaphors and analogies I think
that's a great way to do it you know it
brings home to us these very abstract
ideas that otherwise might might trip us
up
um the idea of not selling ourselves out
for something I think that's quite
valuable
um that everything has a certain kind of
price but that we get to decide whether
we're willing to pay it or not if we're
being conscious of what we're doing I
think that can be quite quite helpful
there are a number of other
um
uh examples of like leading people
through better practical reasoning uh
some of which are in the handouts that I
provided like holding the chamber pot
you know do you do you hold the chamber
pot or do you not do it if that's up to
you you know Epictetus is saying if
you're the kind of person who's willing
to sell yourself out for that then hold
the chamber pot and don't feel bad about
it just go ahead and do it if you think
that that's beneath you well then act a
different way he's got another great
example about familial affection there's
this father who shows up and he's he's
talking with him and he's like how's
married life going and he's like oh it's
uh it's really rough you know my
daughter got sick and I was so filled
with familial affection that I had to
like leave the room and I couldn't stay
with her and Epictetus is like buddy
that's not familial affection and
there's a whole reasoning process that
he leads them through that you can you
can check out there
um he he's got another one in the
handouts about leaving school due to
illness where epictetus's point is hey
you can be sick anywhere buddy
um why not be sick here at school rather
than than go home and there's another
one that I'm really fond of where he get
he has a conversation with a local
official who's all ticked off because he
went to the theater and he got into an
argument with all the rest of the people
in the audience about who should be
awarded a prize and they started
shouting at him and he started shouting
at them and you know he comes to Epic he
just basically looking for some
validation and Epictetus tells them you
know you're the example you're the
official you're the person in charge you
should think through these things better
you know if you want the audience to
behave like decent people
how about you act like a decent person
you know when it comes to these these
sorts of things now what's going on in
all of these cases Epictetus is applying
the remedy of Reason providing reasons
plural for how people ought to use their
own priorases to change that priorasis
to become a little bit better I mean
what was his track record I'll I'll
close with this and then let's do some
more q a he tells us that Socrates was
successful maybe in one case out of a
thousand and that's like a good track
record so it's not as if these are like
automatic on off switches you just point
out to somebody oh you screwed up and
then they automatically are receptive to
you and they're like thank you so much
for helping me fix my my damaged
priorities instead it's going to be a
very uh tough ongoing process that may
involve you know some arguing back and
forth and conflict and they might abuse
you or tell you you're wrong or stuff
like that but he thinks that it does
work you know and that's a good portion
of what he does in his teachings and
what he does in his conversations with
people that are preserved in the the
books that we have of the discourses the
four books of the originally eight that
his his student erian wrote down so
um there's I think there's a lot yet to
that's probably murky about this and I'm
happy to
um do you know sort of a general q a
about any of this stuff um but that's
that's uh
those are my thoughts on on what
Epictetus is doing
um you notice that
most of it is just bringing up what
Epictetus actually says in kind of a
digested form
um I don't know I don't know that what
I'm saying here is particularly uh
new as far as interpretation of
Epictetus but I think it's it's worth
thinking about how how do we make sense
of our own screwed up lives and then um
make them better by by bringing in
reasoning
and other people's reasoning you know
so I'm happy to entertain any questions
or comments
that's a great question about habit and
actions and choices and how we modify
our our priorases and you could think of
the proy races he doesn't actually say
this as such but I think it's something
that you could legitimately draw out of
his his ideas the Prairie races is kind
of a bundle of habits among other things
and those habits are generated in kind
of an Aristotelian way right by doing
the same thing uh in similar
circumstances and he says exactly that
in in a few parts of the um the
discourses he also gives us a lot of
advice about if you want to break a
habit well you've got to like push over
to the Other Extreme you know he uses
the metaphor of a shift a ship that's
kind of like tilted to the side and if
you want it to tilt over you got to push
it further over to the other side so
there's interestingly although Epictetus
the the only things he says about
aristotelians is that they're basically
like not as bad as epicureans but pretty
close
certainly uh says a lot of things that
sound pretty confident with the
Aristotelian conception of virtue ethics
right
by doing the same thing over and over
again we we generate habits
um we got to be really careful too once
we've got a bad habit
um he he talks this may gross people out
a little bit but he talks about like
with anger
um The Habit that you've generated is
sort of like having scar tissue from
being whipped
and then he says if you're giving into
it once you know that you've already got
a habit that's sort of like that goes
beyond just wheels and becomes wounds in
your sort of like in your body but
imagine in your soul right it's more and
more damaging as as time goes on I mean
coming close to what we nowadays call
trauma you know which I think is a big
challenge for for virtue ethics
um so we we have to be yeah we have to
be quite cognizant of the habits that we
have and there's another really
important feature of of uh what he has
to say about habits
so at any moment when we're tempted to
do something on the basis of a bad habit
of a vicious habit
we usually have a line of reasoning that
goes
like this it will say oh it's not a big
deal because I'm only doing it in this
one instance you know
um normally I wouldn't have a midnight
snack but I just gave a good
presentation so I get to indulge myself
right
or normally I wouldn't have lost my
temper but that person was a complete
jackass and and they they had it coming
right and what we don't realize is that
like at every moment we have this little
tiny bit of freedom to improve ourselves
or to to backslide
and
abandoning this habits this sort of meta
habit of excusing ourselves when it
comes to bad habits
that's an important part of moral
Improvement right paying attention to
each situation that we're getting
ourselves in and and not making excuses
for ourselves as we're tempted to do
which is an affective thing right we
already have a habit uh a tendency of
making excuses and there may be all
sorts of other people giving us bad
advice oh it's okay for you to do this
right
um so so yeah this this dimension of
habit is absolutely important for moral
development for for Epictetus and I
would say for the stoics in general I
mean how do you get to be a good person
a virtuous person you know you think
about their their four cardinal virtues
um wisdom courage Temperance and Justice
they're they're not sometimes they're
portrayed as if like you either have one
or you don't and there's no in between
but I think that that's that's certainly
not there in Epictetus and Seneca
sometimes says stuff like that but then
he contradicts himself later on about
the importance of changing things
gradually so I see another question from
Sonia
that's a great that's a great question
about how we become aware of our own
vices right how things things that we
need to fix about ourselves
um
so
sometimes you know he asked is it
because of our the bad consequences yeah
sometimes it is like you know I get
angry and then I get fired from a job or
somebody doesn't fire me but but human
resources sends me to mandatory anger
management classes and now I'm aware
that I have a problem that I need to
work on and actually when I go into the
anger management class I'm probably
resistant the way most people are in the
first couple sessions they're like these
all these other people they've got a
problem not me you know but you know
after a while you you come to see that
nah you're not that different than
everybody else so so now we're already
moving from consequences that you don't
like to like seeing that you aren't that
exceptional
um and and I think he just does talk
about this you know you you uh complain
he says at one point I don't remember
exactly where this is oh you're
complaining about other people and their
own screwed up Behavior but what about
you buddy you know or aren't you like
that yourself Marcus also says that to
himself as well and then you know I
think we talked about this a little bit
earlier in a passage that I brought up
contradictions or conflicts
um
most of us are are not completely
consistent right Epictetus himself cops
to that
um do we get bothered by our
inconsistencies so sometimes this could
be outside people coming in and saying
you know you criticize these people over
here but you yourself do this or I don't
like when you behave this way
um you need to look at this right and
sometimes it's ourselves
um
realizing the contradictions that we've
got ourselves in we're like holy crap my
life is a mess
um I need to start fixing this but you
know this is a kind of an interesting
side note
and this gets away from Epictetus into
you know thinking about moral
development more generally
um
you see that with a lot of people and I
can say this from my own experience and
also a lot of theorists throughout
history
um particularly the monastic writers
that
the first problem that we identify
usually isn't like the main problem
we we see something and we're like oh
this is messed up I need to work on this
and then we start digging into it and
then we're like oh there's even bigger
things down below you know and it's sort
of like um walking into somebody's house
where you're gonna like you're supposed
to like I don't know do a little bit of
light carpentry to help them with their
window actually when I was a kid we
worked on a place like this my my uncle
and I were supposed to paint a house and
as we're painting the house we realized
that there were like boards that were
rotting because they're coming apart as
we're painting it and we're like we're
gonna have to replace these boards and
then he actually taught me how to glaze
Windows because some of the windows had
to be replaced and it turned into this
gigantic project you know well that's
usually the way it works for us when
we're engaged in moral development you
know you get sent to anger management
and you're like yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
learn how to be cool for a while and
then you're like oh I'm angry because
everybody in my family yells at each
other all the time you know I need to
like work on this stuff so
maybe to go back to your your original
question how are we motivated to to
improve ourselves maybe the motivation
can't happen all at once for most of us
you know because we're more screwed up
than we than we realize we are you know
I mean I know that's certainly the case
for me
um I suspect that's probably the case
for most people it's not as if we can
like
do a scientific study of this but you
know
any other uh questions or things you
want to talk more about or
oh okay here we go
um from she I heard there are different
reasonings it's up to you depending on
how you choose but how does the remedy
of reasoning come in how knowing the
other person's reasoning process can
somehow change or correct mine so
there's a lot of ways
um I mean there could be the mirroring
thing that we were talking about you see
somebody else making uh really foolish
arguments and you're like holy crap I'm
glad I'm not like those dummies over
there and then you realize oh wait a
second I am like those dummies over
there you know and so seeing other
people's bad reasonings could somehow
provoke you to realize your own mistaken
reasonings
um I mean sometimes we we start paying
attention to our reasonings because
somebody whose opinion we value tells us
we need to stop screwing up like we're
screwing up and uh you know this this
could be like in my case I'm very
fortunate in that I have a a great wife
who
um
very smart smarter than me
um
quite perceptive you know and uh is um
pretty willing to call me out on stuff
you know but it could be a good friend
it could be a teacher or a mentor it
could be you know if you have if you're
lucky enough to get a good psychologist
or life coach or somebody else who digs
into these sorts of things it might be
that so that's a second way right they
they actually say you need to like start
thinking about this in the course of
psychotherapy people depending on what
kind of modality they're pursuing they
often like explore their own
processes of reasoning and trying to
look for
um
different biases or blank spots where
they're missing something or mistaken
lines of reasoning or stuff like that
um
what else I mean
Epictetus actually is a great model for
this every point in his Works where he
says
have this ready at hand or in a
situation like this be ready to say to
yourself
those are lines of reasoning that he's
offering to us right I mean this is a
bit of a digression but so you know
originally there were eight eight books
of the discourses and
we've lost four of those apparently but
that was just Aryan studying with
Epictetus for a space of like two to
three years and then writing stuff down
imagine if we had like video recordings
and they were of course translated from
ancient koinette Greek into to uh our
languages of Epictetus actually teaching
how many conversations he would have had
how many places where he would have said
when you're in a situation like this try
this out when you're doing this try this
out that's that's
um I think part of the effect of his his
own teaching I mean we have similar
things with Seneca right Seneca writes
these letters to lakilius and he writes
some letters of consolation and he
writes some treaties and he often says
similar things where he's like when you
get into a situation like this try to
look at things this way or try to think
about these these ideas so those are
those remedy of of reasoning
um now how effective are they I mean
it depends on the person it depends on
their willingness to actually listen to
it
um it's not as if you just throw the
right reasoning in front of somebody and
they accept the coinage and they're like
you know a um a vending machine right
where you put in the money and you push
the button and then the soda or candy or
chips comes out uh but you know
we're more complicated than that and and
you can kind of work on people over a
while Gareth it looks like you've got a
a question as well um so there's a
couple interesting things there in your
question
um let me try to
split them apart from each other and
let's talk about the ship of Theseus
thing first right so shipothesis
everyone's familiar with that right
Theseus starts sailing he's got to
replace things along the way at the end
every single piece of the ship has been
replaced is it the same ship well that's
the way that the stoics
um basically look at the human psyche
um you know if reason is just a system
of appearances then you can swap things
out in and out all the time it's I guess
you could say it kind of matters like
what kind of appearance they are maybe
you know
um and and similarly with changing
habits what you're doing in in the prior
races in modifying it by the choices
that you're making is you're you're
swapping some bits out and swapping some
other bits out right and there may be
some that are like harder to move
um like you know if you have some we I
mentioned the word trauma a little bit
earlier I think that one of the big
challenges for virtue ethics in general
is taking adequate account of the
traumas that by the time that we're
adults were were stuck with and
often prove much more intractable to
modification or fixing than the other
parts of ourselves
but even those you know you can
gradually replace those those reactions
and
um
you know reframe memories and things
like that so I think that's that's
that's the hypothesis thing is quite
interesting as far as the indifference
um so there's two things to say one is
one is in direct response to your
question are there actions that are
indifferent yeah and the stoics actually
give examples of them like you know is
your finger bent or is it straight right
straightening your finger bending your
finger who cares it doesn't doesn't
matter now if if I'm like you know if I
take my glasses off and I my fingers
bent and then it's straight and I poke
myself in the eye suddenly it assumes
some importance right and so there could
be a lot of things that I guess you
could say in themselves are in different
actions but when we put them into a
framework or a prime example giving
somebody the middle finger right maybe
you're just counting you know uh but it
could also turn into a gesture that's
you know showing defiance I when I was a
kid I actually had this finger crushed
in a door and I didn't know what the
middle finger meant and so the older
kids were all like hey show us that
injured finger you know and then I'm
like here it is you know and then I got
in trouble with the the teachers it was
like in third grade or so
um so some things that that in
themselves are indifferent within
certain contexts could have could have
value right and you know if you think
about what we count as money
um
now that's not about actions but that's
more about other stuff
you know I grew up
um in a time when cash was important and
people would write checks and then
credit cards were a rarity and now
there's a lot of places where you can't
even use cash you know
um and you know there's all sorts of
other things that we never dreamed of
like Apple pay or Google pay or things
like that what counts as money is is you
know is kind of an indifferent in itself
but when you want to buy a hamburger
it's no longer quite so indifferent to
you it doesn't have the value that makes
you virtuous or vicious but it's
important the third thing to say about
the indifference is
the stoics don't think that we should be
indifferent to all of the indifference
that um using them well or dealing with
them well is in fact as as epictus says
um something could be indifferent but
our use of it is not indifferent and it
is within our control and it is a matter
of the prior races so how I use my money
money itself is an indifferent but how I
use my money is not I can use it
virtuously or viciously you know and
there's all sorts of other things
like that as as well within that that
realm and we could say that about bad
things too like how do I use my sickness
um I'm still suffering from some effects
of Law and covid do I use it uh
um rather cynically as an excuse to get
out of doing work right that's vicious
do I need to like pay attention to
certain things so I don't over exert
myself then wind up being too tired to
fulfill my obligations okay that's more
of a virtuous uh way of dealing with an
indifference of of the body and illness
and stuff like that I see another
question from Sonia though yeah so the
you're asking about
um what the stoics would call
um virtuous or vicious actions and then
appropriate or inappropriate actions or
duties and and what's contrary to duty
and I mean the stoics thought they have
a very robustly developed virtue ethics
and like there's these four cardinal
virtues and each of the virtues has like
subdivisions and so you you can say that
there are some things that are the right
thing to do
um
within you know like almost all
circumstances
um you take for example Seneca in on
anger he says do you need to get angry
in order to prevent your father from
being murdered you know and he says no
you you don't you can do that being
motivated by courage or just by right
practical reasoning uh because you
should keep your father from being
murdered and then you can say well yeah
but what if your father's Hitler you
know or some other horrible but what if
your father's Nero you know somebody who
as we there's some movie where
somebody's like that that's a person who
needs killing you know okay well that's
a little bit different but in most
circumstances it's pretty easy to
identify protecting life as as the right
thing to do right as just thing to do a
courageous thing to do
um there are going to be some tricky
cases
um and then you know we want to use
Prudence as much as we can Prudence is
the stoics Define as like the capacity
or the knowledge uh of what is what is
good for us what is bad for us being
able to like work through processes of
weighing these things and and all of
that so we might need some adjuncts it's
not just like you know responding
immediately in the circumstances
um
but I think that you know that's where
we we look at the other things that they
they have to say
um not that they're going to provide us
with perfect guidance about every single
circumstance they also do think the
motivation matters you know
if you're
doing something that would generally be
seen as a virtuous action but you're
doing it motivated because you want to
have everybody look at you and say wow
what a great person you know as we call
it over here being a big shot you know
um that that changes the action it's
it's it's virtuous and it's good in some
respects but it's bad in other respects
but I mean Aristotle says that too you
know and Plato says that too you know
Plato in the Fado distinguishes
um what most people think of as courage
from philosophical courage you know like
um you you run into the burning building
because you're afraid of looking like
you're scared of the fire that's not
courage according to Plato you're just
transferring one fear to another you
know uh so I think this is kind of a
common thing in virtue ethics there's
like Aristotle has this this great
discussion of acting from virtue right
because you've actually got the virtue
and then just acting in accordance with
virtue being self-controlled and he says
yeah they're both good one's one's way
better than the other you know know and
we could say similar things with vicious
Behavior then the stoics will Define
this primarily in terms of I mean here's
here's one place where I totally
disagree with the stoics they've got
this whole notion of the sage like the
perfect person and only the perfect
person can do perfectly good actions
um they call those cot Ortho Mata as
opposed to Cathay cone Cafe Conta and
the cafe Conta is often translated as
like actions in accordance with Duty or
appropriate actions they're like the
right thing to do but they don't have
like a perfect motivation behind them
whereas the sage this legendary person
who we don't even know if they ever
existed and Epictetus says I'm not a
sage by the way they with them like the
motivational structure is completely
perfect
I I think this is kind of it's not a
very helpful thing it often discourages
people because they're like I can never
be completely good you know
um
but you know we could probably set that
aside
the the sage conception I mean
if Epictetus thought anybody was a sage
it was Socrates diogenes and Xeno
and when you look at all three of them
and the stories that we have about them
they don't seem perfect people I mean
Socrates sure he was a great philosopher
but he is also a terrible father you
know
diogeny seems more like a jerk than a
perfect Herald of God as the cynics like
to call themselves all the time and Xeno
actually was afraid to carry a pot of
lentils across the marketplace so yeah
they all had flaws but each of them had
their their roles as Epictetus says you
know each of them did their their work
and I think that's the best we can
probably aim for you know
I'll say one other thing too in response
to your question
we probably need other people to be
involved with us to call us out on our
BS when we think that we're doing like
perfectly good stuff and we're being we
we've like Advanced and we're you know
at the Pinnacle of goodness uh we
probably need other people in the
background to say oh no no you're not
you're not quite so good you still have
some work to do on yourself you know
so she says I want to ask about
coherence I think that was mentioned at
the very beginning
in the title
um I mean I I don't have coherence in
the title character is the the c word in
the title but you can say that that for
the stoics and again not uniquely right
um coherence our ideas and our actions
and our character being coherent as
opposed to being contradictory or in
conflict with each other
um that's that's really important
um and I think that's that's a place
where
you could say that that virtue ethics
intersects with with Psychotherapy and
with with other things as well because
you know we do want to be generally
coherent in the things that we desire
and commit to and and prioritize and
choose to do
um and we you know we want that
coherence to be
you could say one that's oriented
towards the good because I suppose you
could be more or less coherently evil
you know in some respect yeah I mean you
would be incoherent on other levels for
the stoics but
um there are some examples of people who
seem to be you know very well developed
in in in doing evil so you know
coherence yeah that that's that's
um
so that's something that Epictetus talks
about with just a single term but you
could say that that is something
in the background
for
um stoic ethics in general
um the whole idea of living in
accordance you know
um in accordance is translating several
different Greek terms one of which is
um uh harmonia right which is is
definitely like concordance or or
coherence so
[Music]
so yeah I think that's that's a good
thing to highlight
um well again thanks so much for for
having me here and I very much enjoyed
spending this time with you and uh
yeah I hope that I hope the handouts are
are helpful for you and uh I'll maybe
see some of you again in The Ether and
uh maybe someday I'll
be there in Wurzburg